hallo herzlich willkommen in sallyis
Welt ich stehe heute nicht in wäusel
sondern bei mir im Shop in Mannheim und
zwar ist hier heute richtig Stimmung ich
habe ganz viele Gäste da und wir warten
alle auf einen Star wir warten heute auf
dicka dicka ist mein Freund er ist das
singende Nashorn und er macht so viele
Kinder immer glücklich mit seiner tollen
Musik
[Musik]
und ich habe mir gedacht wir machen
heute ein schönes Weihnachtsspecial das
heißt wir werden gemeinsam mit dicker
backen wir werden singen wir werden
basteln und wir schauen einfach mal so
was der Tag so mit sich bringt also ich
an sich bin ja bereit jetzt fehlt
eigentlich nur noch ein Gast und das ist
der dicker und der ist bis heute hier
noch nicht
aufgetaucht die Handschuhe habe ich
schon bereit denn dicker hat ziemlich
große Hände größer als meine und ich
glaube die brauche er auch gleich zum
Backen das hier nicht alles einsauen ich
brauche jetzt aber erstmal tatkräftige
Unterstützung habe ganz viele Kinder da
und ich würde sagen wir rufen jetzt alle
mal dicker dass er kommt dicker dicker
dicker
dickerckck ich sehe
ihn dick dick
dickckck
e hey Leute geht's euch gut hallöchen
unglaublich
hallöchen S darf ich zu dir kommen du
darfst zu mir kommen oh ich bin so
aufgeregt oh ich bin
aufgeregt guck mal ich habe mich extra
auf weihnachtlich vorbereitet du bist ja
richtig vorbereitet richtig
Weihnachtsstimmung wir sehen toll aus
oder
Leute mein Gott ich kann es gar nicht
glauben für mich geht auch ein Traum in
Erfüllung dicker steht bei mir in der
Küche das ja unglaublich Krien das schon
gebacken oder ja wir kriegen das
gebacken also dicker ich habe mir
gedacht ich bereite mal ein bisschen was
vor ich weiß nicht hast du mal gebacken
nicht wirklich aber naschst du gerne ja
ja was sind denn so deine
Lieblingsplätzchen also ich mag sehr
gerne
vanillekppfer und ich mag sehr gerne
ganz normale Plätzchen und ich mag
schattige Plätzchen wir machen heute
alles worauf wir Lust haben würde ich
jetzt mal sagen super cool du hast ja
schon richtig viel vorbereitet hier ja
ich habete Zuckerstreusel ich habe auch
ich habe sogar was von dir da warte mal
guck mal guck mal ich habe extra
Streusel mitgebracht dicker Streußel in
den
dickerfarben super bunt und super frech
habe ich dir mitgebracht können wir
vielleicht auch drauf machen das ist
mega cool boah ich bin richtig aufgeregt
ich habe noch nie mit einem nason und
mit dicker gebacken wir schaffen das
oder wir backen jetzt was richtig
richtig tolles möchtest du vielleicht
auch eine Schürze ja sehr sehr gerne
wenn du eine für mich hast ich habe eine
ich habe leider nur eine Größe ich weiß
auch nicht ob die dir passt aber das
kriegen wir schon hin ne das schaffen
wir ne ich TR die gerne vielleicht kann
ich die Kette so vielleicht kann ich die
Kette so die Kette die ma mal
drüber ist die aus echtem Gold ja die
ist aus echtem nashorngold ne ganz
nachhaltig davon habe ich auch
Schlüsselanhänger und so krass schau mal
steht mir das kann ich tragen oder
Leute so die Pfötchen sind schon
gewaschen ja pötchen sind gewaschen ich
habe aber extra zum Backen auch Nashorn
backhandschuhe mitgebracht ja die habe
ich hier schau mal wir sind wirklich
vorbereitet
Leute okay gut ne dicker ich glaube so
groß und stark wie du willist bräuchte
ich dich öfter in der Küche zum
teigneten sehr gut sehr gerne machen wir
so ich habe mir gedacht wir könnten
erstmal Kekse ausrollen okay K ich bin
dabei super wer von euch hat schon mal
Plätzchen gebacken wow so
viele wenn wir nicht weiterkommen könnt
ihr uns auch helfen oder
definitiv
guck mal soll ich dich einfach soll ich
dir ein bisschen Anleitung geben ja
bitte also hier ein bisschen Mehl
okay dann brauchen wir ein bisschen Teig
den hast du schon vorbereitet oder kann
man den habe ich vorbereitet das ist der
ein Z D Teig okay weißt du warum ein Z D
weil er so schnell geht ja und weil man
einfach nur ein Teil Zucker braucht zwei
Teile Butter und drei Teile Mehl kann
man sich super merken das kann sogar ich
mir merken das kann sich jer supermärken
ein Teil Butter ein Teil Zucker
eben ein Teil Zucker zwei Teile Butter
drei Teile Mehl genau und so schnell
kann man schon ein Rezept auswendig habt
ihr euch auch gemerkt also ein Teil
Zucker zwei Teile Butter drei
Teile perfekt ihr seid alles Konditoren
habt heute eine konditorenausbildung
abgeschlossen guck mal dicker stehen
bestimmt auch ein paar kleine
Weltmeisterin und backweltmeister vor
uns stim jetzt darfst du den ausrollstab
nehmen und einfach mal ausrollen okay
hier auf dem Rand ne so ja ich habe das
noch nie gemacht echt ihr K was ist denn
so ein Nashorn NAS was Nashorn ist Heu
ach Heu okay he und ein bisschen und am
wisst ihr was ich am liebsten esse
Pommes mit Mayo siehst du Pommes mit
Mayo wissen Bescheid ganz aufmerksame
Kinder hier wow das ist ist doch schon
Weihnachtsmann hier ja das schon
Weihnachts
noch noch mal quer oder so ja das sieht
doch perfekt
aus ach dicker Spitze das macht echt
Spaß mit dir oder guck mal und hier
haben wir
Ausstecher in allen Farben und allen
Größen allen Formen wow oh wow
mm hier Blumen Blumen hast auch ner hast
du Safari wir haben keine Nashörner aber
wir können später trotzdem ein Nashorn
machen das W cool das wäre super das
kriegen wir bestimmt hin also ich fange
jetzt mal an hier so weit wie möglich am
Rand auch oder damit damit so viel Teig
wie möglich übrig bleibt
bissh und wo kann ich das dann hinmachen
und dann nehmen wir hier ein Blech du
musst ein bisschen Nachsehen haben okay
ich wenn ich hier ein bisschen Chaos
mache du alles okay aber haupsache
schmeckt lecker hauptsache es
schmeckt Leute schaut mal mein erstes
Plätzchen aller Zeiten hat er super
gemacht oder super
dicker
perfekt super und wenn manche Menschen
vielleicht keine Lust haben
auszustechen oder das nicht so gut
können wie Du man kann auch immer mit
einem Eisportionierer so kleine hübsche
Kekse machen das Wahsinn so das das ist
das ist gebackenes Eis ja das sieht aus
wie Eis das ist ja spitze hast du dir
selber ausgedacht das habe ich mir
ausgedacht ja wow du denkst die ganz
schön viele Sachen aus auch ne ja s
sagen
ja du auch wie du dir die Songs
ausdenkst denke ich mir die Rezepte aus
was ist den dein persönlicher
Lieblingssong mein ganz persönlicher
Lieblingssong aller Zeiten ja ich glaube
wenn ich wirklich gefragt werden würde
was mein lieblingster Lieblingssong
aller Zeiten ist dann sind das dann ist
das wahrscheinlich bis zum Mond das ist
auch mein Lieblingssong den habe ich
meiner kleinen nasorfreundin Dicky
geschrieben ne die hat den dann
eingesungen dann habe ich auch ein
bisschen bisschen verdrückt im Studio
aber die sind ich finde die alle toll
auch auch wenn ich sie nicht selber
gemacht hätte würde ich die super super
toll
findenakaka ja der ist auch cool also
mein allerliebster Lieblingssong ist
auch bis zum Mond kennt ihr den ja den
kann nämlich meine Tochter Ella komplett
auswendig und manchmal singt sie mir den
einfach ganz alleine vor im Bett und
dann muss ich auch immer ein Tränchen
verdrücken der ist richtig süß und
natürlich super Mama super Mama ne ja
habe ich mir F schemach wer kennt das
Lied Supermama wollen wir zusammen
singen superma
[Musik]
super
super kriegt das
gebacken guck mal ich habe auch schon
ein Blech voll du bist ja super schnell
das ist ja schon riesen voll Applaus für
S hat das erste Blech schon voll an
dieser Stelle
wow das stell ich mal kurz Backofen was
passiert mit dem Teig der hier nicht
reinkomt knte den den kann man heimlich
naschen oder den kann man natürlich
naschen
natürlich ich wollt gerade sagen nicht
zu viel kriegt man Bauch weh guck mal
ich mache jetzt hier mal ein bisschen
hinne wow das sieht super aus ich habe
auch schon fast das Viertel Blech
voll bisschen helfenit Z hier man könnte
auch was Größeres nehmen so ach du
machst so schnell ne dann ma wir hier
noch zackack ach me
a zack Leute Applaus für di Applaus guck
mal dein erstes Blech mein erstes Blech
und man kann jetzt wenn man richtig viel
Fantasie hat dann ist es hier ein
Rentier ja was gerade aus der Dusche
kommt schau mal hier ist die Nase hier
ist das Ohr die Beine und der kleine
Schwanz und so rumgeschaut sieht auch
aus wie ein Hund ja stimmt alle dürfen
dabei sein wow Blech schaut mal komm das
darfst du jetzt auch in Ofen
schieben hier ich bin so aufgeregt das
ist das erste mal backen jetzt und dann
auch gleich mit dir ne du bist ja die
größte backpriserin aller Zeiten kannst
du mir warte genau hier kann man es
einfach reinlegen so tschüss und wie
lange brauchen die jetzt ungefähr t so
10 Minuten ich habe noch nie
gebacken also noch nie so professionell
ne guck mal hier die sind alle schon
fertig die sind alle schon fertig also
so sehen dann die Kekse aus die ich
gerade gemacht habe richtig hübsch wie
heißen die denn da darfst du dir jetzt
Namen überlegen das sind
mandelglückskekse ja mandelglückskekse
nennen wir die und das hier sind einfach
Kekse die wir jetzt dekorieren können
das sind die auf die Plätzchen fertig
los Plätzchen ja und wir haben nicht mal
ein Countdown gemacht ne wollen wir alle
zusammen sagen auf die Plätzchen fertig
los s wird hier wild
dekoriert ja wollen wir das machen
wollen wir zusammen auf die Plätzchen
fertig los laut und dann wird los
dekoriert seid ihr
dabei auf die Plätzchen fertig los okay
auf geht's Leute ich
Schokolade ich pass auf den
Weihnachtsmann auf soange hier guck
mal da ist schon mal Schokolade
geschmolzen und du darfst die hier noch
Einrühren in die Schokolade richtiges
Labor hier mega schnell rein ja schmilzt
wie
rührend ich weiß auch nicht ob dir
aufgefallen ist aber ich dachte mir wenn
du kommst ja dann ziehe ich mir mein
Leopardenkleid an dann komme ich als
Leopard gen können wir mal bitte einen
riesengroßen Applaus für Sally haben sie
hat sich
extra habe gedacht wenn mein Freund des
nason kommt dann komme ich als Leopard
da hast du gedacht dann schmeißt du dich
tierisch in Schale oder ja tierisch in
Schale geschmissen heute super okay guck
mal ist ja fast auch schon wieder weg
das geht so schnell ja das sieht super
aus das macht man in Wasser heiß ne das
ein Wasserbad genau einfach übers
Wasserbad und am besten nicht kochen
lassen damit da kein Wasser in die
Schokolade kommt und damit die auch
nicht zu heiß wird sonst flockt sie rum
oder genau und dann wird ja auch nicht
mehr schön fest und so hat s jetzt
gleich die perfekte Temperatur so und
eigentlich können wir jetzt direkt
starten und du kannst hier die Kekse so
eintauchen zur Hälfte und ich lass uns
gleich noch ein Tellerchen bringen oder
so ein irgendwas ah warte mal wir legen
es da drauf zum Trocknen machen wir hier
drauf das ist ja das ist ja der Hit oder
und dann können wir deine sträuselchen
da draufen genau ich mach das mit machen
wir das nur mit den oder auch mit den
und mit den auch da können wir auch
alles einfach einintunken ne halb halb
reintunken so wie du
möchtest denkt immer das ist backen ist
so kompliziert aber W wenn ich das bei
dir an ich es bei dir angucke dann ist
das so wie mm ich sag immer jeder kann
backen ja jeder kann backen oder wer von
euch hat schon mal gebackt wer von euch
hat schon mal Kekse gebacken ich was mit
den großen Kindern da hinten habt ihr
auch schon mal Kekse gebacken ja ne ihr
dürft auch ihr dürft euch auch melden
und wer hat schon mal Kekse
gegessen habe ich mir schon fast gedacht
super cool und jetzt machen wir da was
drauf oder bleiben so a wie kleine Igel
wir machen da natürlich was drauf das
hast du hier schon hingelegt ne ich kann
sochen ja du kannst so machen oh das ja
guck mal das sind auch riesengroße
nasonkugeln hier mit drin guck mal ich
ma mal so ich will auch nur mal betonen
dass der kaput Keks das war ich der ist
mir kaputt gegangen welcher denn zeig
mal der ist das der sieht aus als hätte
ich ihn angebissen aber ich habe nicht
reingebissen versprochen der sieht aber
trotzdem guck mal der auch wenn man ein
kleinen Knicks hat sieht man super super
toll aus ja okay das geht jetzt hier
wolltet ihr denn auch schon immer mal
was wissen von dicker dann kann ich ihm
noch eine Frage stellen wollte jemand
was wissen ich gehe mal kurz schauen
wollt jemand von euch mal dicker eine
Frage stellen hat jemand eine Frage ja
wie alt ist er oh oh das ist eine Frage
du ih fragst und nicht mich bin also ich
weiß dass in nason Jahen bin ich so
ungefähr zwischen so und so irgendwo
dazwischen immer aber eigentlich bin ich
so so ich war zwischen wie alt bist du
denn ze ja so ungefähr auch ich bin fünf
du bist F wie alt seid ihr denn alle
könnt ihr mal bei drei sagen wie alt ihr
seid 1 2
D best bestes Alter der
Welt
sieht so toll aus oh sorry jetzt habe
ich hier re sieh richtig toll aus
reingedippt das macht überhaupt nicht
das ist ein Wunder dass das eigentlich
von da dann direkt aufs Blech geht
eigentlich der reflexartige Bewegung
gleich Mund so direkt im Mund ne ja ich
ich
weiß so ich weiß nicht boah sind die
schön die sehen wunderhübsch aus guck
mal hier unten
so alles klar habe ich noch Platz hier
ich mach das hier wir haben hier noch
Platz ich würde jetzt noch so ein paar
machen weil die Kinder spterlich
auchierenen wenn die Eltern erlauben ja
müssen wir natürlich die Eltern vorher
fragen ob Allergien oder irgendwas
bestehen das stimmt allerdings ne guck
mal kann man einfach so
rauf manchmal ist bei mir auch so wenn
ich merke oh heute ist nicht so ein
toller Tag streue ich einfach Glitzer
drauf ja super und den Glitzer den man
den man der daneben geht den kann man ja
danach den kann man auch wieder benutzen
guck man kann die auch so
reindippen zack okay das ist aber cool
das finde ich super cool jetzt ist es
voll machen wir noch eins davon ich habe
auch eine Frage an euch geht's euch gut
ja ist jemand von euch aufgeregt ja wir
auch oder ich auch ich bin auch richtig
aufgeregt wer guckt zum ersten Mal zu
wie eine backkönigin und ein Nashorn
Kekse
backen ich
auch so und so das ist eine Oma guck mal
mit der hat so ein Scheitel hier hier
das sind das sind die Augen super was
ist hiermit das spielt noch keine Rolle
ne das also das ist einfach gem das ist
einfach nur so da okay und jetzt hast du
hast ja auch ganz viel Zeug ganz viel
tolle Sachen mit gan viele tolle Sachen
die können wir auch noch benutzen W will
bitte sehr gerne super s die auch noch
draufuen auf jeden Fall einfach alles
drauf einfach alles gib ihm einmal bunt
ja einmal Bund mit Ansage der passt hier
noch hin und wie feierst du dieses Jahr
Weihnachten ich ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich glaub dieses Jahr baue ich den
Baum sehr sehr früh auf ja weil ich das
immer voll schade finde dass der Baum
dann Heilig Abend steht und dann weiß
jemand von euch wann die Bäume immer
weggeräumt werden ich glaube am am 6
januar oder ich glaube ne 6 Januar so
ich finde das eigentlich das schönste
den Baum zu schmücken und dieses Jahr
möchte ich den Baum auch selber
schmücken und Sachen malen und wir haben
so aus Papierkugeln erstm wir haben
Sachen gemalt Butt auf dem Blatt Papier
haben das dann zusammengeknüllt und
haben es mit Fäden an den Baum gehängt
und das ist voll schön guck mal die
sehen so die sehen ja filmreif aus die
könntest du ja auch so ein Baum schön
oder oder passt da noch was drauf darf
ich da noch was kleines drauf machen
Marshmallow oder so K natürlich bist ein
richtiger backprofi jetzt schon ne aber
nur weil ich neben dir stehen darf da
bin ich auch super mutig dann dann traut
man sich auch sowas hier zu machen guck
mal das ist ganz schön und was sind den
das hier kleine das sind kleine
Lebkuchenmännchen sind die sind die
wirklich aus Lebkuchen nein die sehen
nur so aus darf ich auch noch ja na
klar und am Ende wenn ihr zu Hause auch
Plätzchen backt und ihr habt noch
Schokolade übrig und ein bisschen
Streusel und habt aber vielleicht keine
Plätzchen mehr dann könnt ihr da einfach
Cornflakes reinschmeißen bisschen Nüsse
oder getrocknete Früchte Mini
Marshmallows und dann kann man daraus
einfach so eine Resteverwertung machen
und kleine Häufchen aufs Blech geben und
hat so kleine schokogrossies das ja das
ist ja das ist ja der beste Tipp des
Universums einfach rin einfach alles
rein oh das ist aufregend ach so daraus
kann man d das kann ja die müssen nicht
gebacken werden die müssen dann nur in
den Kühlschrank mit den Marshmallows und
so und was ist denn das für Schokolade
die da drin ist ganz normale Schokolade
so Tafelschokolade Z bitterchokolade
also kurveratüre okay okay was kommt
noch rein Mandeln Mandeln wir machen
auch noch ein das war auch das waren
gehackte jetzt nehmen wir die gehobelten
vielleicht so ja perfekt und ich hole
kurz eine Folie zum drauf machen SP okay
also das sieht eigentlich schon fast
fast top aus oder ja das sieht super aus
oder nimmst du nämlich einfach so einen
Portionierer ich ma den mal sauber na ja
danke schön aufregend Leute oder
Plätzchen
machen und so entstehen dann einfach
neue Rezeptideen stimmt allerdings wie
nennen wir denn das hier ja da brauchen
wir jetzt auch ein Namen dafür wie
nennen wir denn wie wollen wir das denn
nennen wo wir alles reingeschmissen
haben in die
schokoladeol dicker Schokolade
[Musik]
schokoladechmchokolade mischmaschokolade
dicker mischm
cker dicker Mischmasch zirkuschol bitte
Glitzer glitzerschokolade okay dicker
glitchokolade finde ich auch gut dicker
glitzerschokolade jetzt kannst du
damit einfach so kleine Häufchen machen
das passt ja perfekt was mache ich hierm
das kann ich hier drauf kannst du da
drauf legen und dann könen wir die noch
so hübsch dekorieren sorry wenn ich ein
bisschen rumschweine hier okay okay und
das als Nashorn und das als Nashorn
oder dabei sind NAS eigentlich super
stubenreih ne die machen auch immer ja
die passen ganz doll auf auf ihr
zuuhause und machen immer haben eine
eigene Toilette ach das ja schön ja du
da kannst du öfter vorbeikommen bei ja
du kannst mich auch mal in Berliner Zoo
besuchen kommen im neuen nashornhhaus
dann machen wir da einfach ein paar
Plätzchen das machen wir auf jeden Fall
ja dann würde ich sagen backen wir hier
noch die Plätzchen fertig und ihr dürft
dann auch gleich probieren
und super cool zepte gibt's auch zum
Nachmachen in der App natürlich und alle
Songs von dicker könnt ihr rauf und
runter hören gerade jetzt in der
Weihnachtszeit hast du fünf neue Songs
ja ich habe fünf neue dicker
Weihnachtslieder ich habe
weihnachtsminialbum gemacht das heißt
lasst uns frech und munter sein hat das
jemand schon gehört die dicker
Weihnachtslieder h mal 100 mal das heißt
du kannst mitsingen oder wer möchte
gleich
naschen zum Glück haben wir genug Kekse
gemacht guck mal wir machen das jetzt
und wie lange muss das im wie lange muss
das im im Kühlschrank sein eigentlich
nur Z D Minuten und dann sind die fertig
habt ihr noch 2 D Minuten Zeit ja zum
Naschen ja dann würde ich sagen holen
wir gleich die Plätzchen raus die Kinder
dürfen probieren und dann ja machen wir
uns einen schönen Nachmittag hier wir
probieren auch oder wir probieren
natürlich auch oder kennst du kennst du
ein Bällebad bist du hast du schon mal
ein Bällebad warst du schon mal in so
ein keksebad also kann man in die Kekse
reinrutschen nein oh das wä eine schöne
Idee jaw das wäre richtig toll würdest
du einmal eintauchen also e super vielen
Dank lass dich mal drücken super riesen
vielen Dank für die Einladung dan danke
dass du mit mir gebacken hast sehr sehr
gerne GL wir machen heute ganz viele
hungrige Kinder ganz schön satt mit
unseren Plätzchen und Keksen vielen Dank
euch zu Hause fürs Einschalten wir
verteilen jetzt hier noch alles schön
die Rezepte gibt's natürlich online
dikas Musik überall zu streamen
und ich freue mich richtig dass du da
bist ich freue mich auch sehr ich bin
riesen aufgeregt das war leute passt
immer drauf auf dass ihr im Leben ganz
ganz viele erste Male immer noch vor
euch habt es war heute ein weiteres
erstes Mal in meinem Leben vielen Dank
für die super tolle Einladung von Dir
bin riesengroßer Fan danke dass wir hier
sein dürfen und schön riesen Applaus an
S bitte an dieser Stelle und Applaus
[Applaus]
anck und ihr bleibt noch kurz dran denn
am Ende gibt noch ein richtig schönes
tolles Gewinnspiel für euch lasst euch
überraschen super voll schön und wer hat
jetzt Lust auf Kekse oh oh oh oh oh oh
wir wünschen ein fruhe Weihnacht auf die
Plätzchen fertig
los